hey guys marry kiss here speaking the
words of Kevin Van Wert to talk to you
about the sims for The Sims series means
many things to many people let's say you
think of the Sims as a dollhouse in some
cases the sims 4 fulfills this role with
some success if you want to build but
prefer not to micromanage the details
the game comes with various pre-arranged
rooms if you're devoted to architecture
and interior design you have a
streamlined set of buying and building
tools that make it easy to create and
decorate stretching and dragging walls
into properly modular rectangles is as
easy as knowing how to use a mouse and a
keyboard finding an item is as simple as
typing a keyword into a search field and
selecting the best match given the
conflation of two modes into one and the
right amount of categories to sift
through the sims 4 does a pretty
credible job of leading you right to the
objects and the tools that you're
seeking on the surface there would seem
to be more than enough styles and
objects from which to choose when the
time comes to set up a life of leisure
however the boundaries become a little
bit more rigid than they first appear
The Sims 3s create a style option has
been dropped leaving only predetermined
colors in their place color can make a
great through line for aesthetically
linking various shapes and styles but
you quickly find that objects don't
always have the same hues available
between them mixing and matching can
make a room look more random than
refined the creative style option
provided a means of connecting disparate
decor and it's lost diminishes
creativity
but let's say you think of the sims for
more as a life simulation even then the
sims 4 feels diminished when compared to
even the vanilla version of the sims 3
there's already been a lot said about
the features that didn't make the cut
but even if you don't have a list of
those features on hand the squashed
review is a parent your initial law may
be too small for you to erect the
gigantic starter telescope previous Sims
modders and des sims 2 expansion had
already introduced microscopes into the
mix but you might have too little room
for the lab quality Colossus in the Sims
4
almost everything you want to do comes
with annoying limitations the sims 4 has
presents to give to in the form of new
kinds of social interactions objects and
other charming detours multitasking is
at the forefront of these changes sims
will hilariously use the toilet while
playing games on the tablet or drinking
some orange juice Sims can be moody
getting embarrassed when you send one
sim to the shower when another is
already on the toilet or getting a
little Randy when they're near their
spouses Sims also gain access to new
kinds of social interactions when they
get moody like angry Sims getting in
fights or embarrassed Sims needing
reassurance focus Sims wanting to play
chess and so on and so forth changes in
mood are accompanied by ridiculous
exclamations in gibberish language known
as Simlish listening to snobby
mischievious Sims mock other people's
outfits is almost as fun as watching
them strut around like they're all that
watching a sim open and closed books
like mouths and mimicking what they
might say before cracking them open and
actually reading is always a trip
watching your sims in action means
having a frequent smile stretched across
your face
[Music]
turning these individual activities into
long-form stories isn't as compelling as
it was in The Sims 3 however the
previous games were open-world allowing
for seamless travel and smooth multi-sim
control it's been replaced by smaller
Lots
separated by loading screens having to
stare at your loading screen while you
want to travel back to the park is so
distracting but moving back to your home
lot to maintain other family members and
then just finding them standing stiffly
in front of your house is even more so
the deeper you wish to go the more
roadblocks you stumble upon no bikes to
ride or Hills to break the line of sight
no swimming pools and no graveyard Sims
fours biggest problem is that the Sims 3
exists and describing where it stumbles
by necessity means looking at where the
series has been this is a lovely and
lively game that elicits constant smirks
but the sims fours moments never feel
like part of a bigger picture
[Music]